that is a really impressive analysis you
put forward yeah you are you're keeping
up with the corridor i was about to say
i thought i just watched a corridor crew
breakdown or a behind-the-scenes feature
what is happening there reject nation we
are going to watch from new rock stars
today the book of boba fett episode six
easter eggs and breakdown that's right
yep we're starting on episode six today
i know you guys have been asking for a
while it's just been a little bit hard
with the schedule especially because we
gotta adjust our sleep patterns with the
whole peacemaker the following it's been
a lot but we figured we'll do our best
to do the last two and at least we'll
probably be late to the last one for
this as well because i'm gone all day
the day then the last one comes out just
giving you a heads up before you start
complaining at us anyway let's get to it
people hit that like button if you can
that last episode was some of the best
star wars i've ever seen let's get into
this
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
above event episode six from the desert
comes a stranger an episode ironically
filled with familiar faces familiar
music familiar trauma so filled that
bubba pet is really
i cannot help but squeal like a gamorian
at all this nostalgia porn because
there's actually so much in this episode
that is easy to miss trust me in a
deeper meaning to why we are seeing luke
and grogu jedi hour on this boba fett
series all right let's get this out of
the way a lot of people i saw on social
media especially saying like about boba
not being in it yeah it's funny that
boat was barely fitted yes they only had
like a minute of screen time if i'm not
mistaken i've heard some people say guys
it's like a book you know they don't
always focus on the main character and
i've heard a lot of people jump to the
defense of i don't get what the big deal
is right people are surprised the
showrunner said that this would be
mandalorian season 2.5 to that i'd say
most people don't get that message
while i'm not personally perturbed by it
i do think it's kind of a humorous
discussion that's been going around it's
just one of the most memorable parts of
this journey of book of boba fett is how
in the best episodes he's not even into
damage so we open on the spinning veins
of a moisture evaporator now in
engineering of these vapor spires the
veins really serve as a humidity sensor
a way of determining how much moisture
on the day can be coaxed from the air
and condensed in water through these
chilling bars so these veins i love they
thought all this happened
to storm a bruin it's literally a prime
moisture collection day here on the
outskirts of most pell go free town a
matter of life and death for these
desert dwellers all interfered with
because of this stupid drug deal two
ways the pikes are threatening tatooine
and must be interesting
pictures in the same kind of chess that
we saw in episode two and their credits
are kept in the same kind of camto
storage unit used throughout these
series based on the ice cream maker prop
carried by willrow hood on cloud city
and empire strikes back good ol wilrow
always going to get a shout out every
time one of these things shows up god
bad the beth rivers ruthen returns
chapter 9
in that classic western gunslinger
already on his blaster the same frame
that they used on han solo in a new hope
when he approached jabba and then solo
story
[Music]
a special edition cobb says and these
stripes
indicate i'm the marshall of said
territories yeah those red stripes on
white is the same insignia on the
marshall badge captain carson tiva gave
cara dune minus the new republic icon
meaning these stripes are a widely
accepted symbol of authority in the
outer rim the pikes choose violence and
he takes down three of the four but
notice he only actually fires twice the
first shot taking out two of the pikes
the second just taking out the third guy
but the way those last two were lined up
he could have gotten them both something
this final pike realizes as cobb tells
him
you see there's a hard one
yeah probably an involuntary gesture
from timothy elephant but the wink needs
the same kind of thing like trust me but
i'll also kill you wait a minute was
that a real oh my god is that a
reactional weight guy
i gotta i gotta look back at that it was
a real week i didn't even notice that
week before
that's what we live for forget all the
windmills [ __ ] and all that it's the
timothy hall of our wink there's only
one of them in known existence and it's
here also that gusty opening shot also
showed how this is a perfect windy day
for scattering some spice dust taken off
the streets flowing down wind probably
some panther who is high as a kite now
actually what i really do love about how
they decided to bookend this with cop
vance story they start him off as his
badass gunslinger like out of a western
it's like oh this must be the desert
stranger that they're talking about with
the title card like this must be his
episode so it's kind of like a mislead
for when eventually cad bane does show
up it's so cool to like have your
opening shot be bad that cod bath he's a
badass gun singer don't mess with this
guy he'll take you down and then to be
met with the ultimate bounty hunter
yeah that's a really cool visual
storytelling mando pilots his custom n1
starfighter to the planet where luke
brought grogu after we last saw them in
the mandalorian season finale now to be
clear this planet is not identified it
is the same planet where luke had his
school the one destroyed in the last
jedi flashbacks but that planet was
deliberately never identified in star
wars canon like this is not alfrana that
was a rocky or world that luke and lord
santeka visited with ben solo years
after this in legends after the empire
fell luke did build a new school in
yavin iv but the audio description this
episode just calls this a verdant planet
and i think if it was yavin 4 they would
say so like we don't see the massive red
main planet of yavin that you have
before orbits as a moon there's no
temple of massache anywhere folks like
the many sightings of gibberish orabesh
in the show sometimes it's okay to just
not have an answer yet and amanda's
cockpit the controller
tell us created from when anakin piloted
one of these in phantom menace but
remember with anakin they were red
because that fighter was initially on
autopilot for him but they shifted to
blue when r2 released the controls as
they are now with mando also you'll
notice the radar navigation is now on
the left instead of the right and pele
added that booster switch and there's
also a new display in orange and red in
the upper right with orbesh that
translates to att psi psi being a unit
for pressure maybe an adjustment for the
exposed droid port now being closed off
in a jump seat although when mando lands
and hops out briefly the camera does
freeze
that's beautiful well done fellaini
assume those beeps translate to hey i
once piloted one of those naboo
starfighters with the future war
criminal whose son is now the dean of
the new school we're building a life
crazy mando sees a boulder rising we
think by itself or behind the ridge as
if maybe luke or grosgoop might be doing
some rock force bench in like luke did
on dagobot instead this is actually in
the mandibles of an ant droid a new form
of tekken star wars i love these things
because like ants their bodies are
segmented into three cubes colored white
and blue are two's colors and you'll
notice their front cube is larger with a
photoreceptor in order to see over their
cargo that they're carrying just like
our two's photoreceptor and then one of
these checks in with r2 they have this
little exchange they android nods just
seems like r2 might be the ant queen of
this colony who runs this hide mine you
know
what this just really made me think that
star wars should include one of their
live action pieces we've seen the mod
gangs and such where they do upgrades
and the fact that we have these ads that
are built directly modeled after like
real ants of what makes them operable
and work so well i want to see like the
droid makers yeah that guy the guy like
just an episode that you encounter
someone who's like building a droid
modeling after something just some like
awesome tone boom thing it's a pinocchio
type of story in a way yeah right yeah
god i never even thought of that that
would be brilliant a specified live
action for everyone starts yelling at me
about like
this story
yes they are building the jedi school
that we saw in the last jedi flashbacks
the building that they eventually
complete is that same beehive shaped
structure that we saw at the center of
the surrounding additions in dorm huts
that are visible later on the same
school where luke will train his nephew
ben solo before luke freaks out and
scares the [ __ ] out of pen leading to
his defection the kylo ren comics
actually showed that it was not ben who
went on a killing spree and burned down
the temple but instead a bolt of
lightning from snoke
uh palpatine and then ben solo fled and
later on adopted the identity of kylo
ren
who's meditation session is introduced
with these beautiful shots of nature
swain bamboo light beaming through the
leaves and just gorgeous music
who would it meditate here man
the flute is live vigorous grogu theme
music we heard when we first learned the
name of grogu grogo and i can feel each
other's thoughts
[Music]
who gets distracted every time
[Music]
yoda did for him lifting the entire
x-wing from the swamp water now we gotta
say the vfx on luke's face is a solid
improvement this time they put less of
his dialogue on screen in close-up at
least at first in the episode all right
let's go for a walk since mouth movement
is really the hardest part of this
animation reportedly lucasfilm also
hired youtubers shimooki sheppard much
better deep fake of luke after the
mandalorian season two finale mark
hamill returns to voice luke here though
it sounds like they directed him to
deliver his lines in a calmer more zen
state in order to avoid having to
animate a lot of facial emotion this is
all just especially impressive when you
realize we're really just watching two
puppets one practical one digital
some good way to put that it's kind of
subtle when you put it that way
you see uncanny valley freaking daylight
under his body meaning they must have i
guess keyed out the puppeteer or use vfx
to do this the fact that we can't yeah
it's amazing
toddler is magic luke tells groovy yeah
it's amazing i love how he force lifts
him to keep up his name was yoda
he was small like you
but his heart was huge
he once said to me
size matters not
that's how he talked
he would speak in riddles yes you can
hear john williams yoda theme in there
which always brings tears to my eyes
size matters not is the first time we
see this luke in this episode speak in
close up and yeah it is pretty hard to
animate the impact of the s and the t
consonants which sit at the front of the
mouth especially using your lips and
your teeth however i gotta say it's
pretty clever of them to delay this
close-up until we get to a line that is
a specific meaningful callback to the
original trilogy because mentally all of
us viewing this might be focused less on
the mouth instead thinking back to yoda
and empire in that
scene it's too big
size matches not
look like me
just mean by my size do you
major props to standard actor graham
hamilton who replaced max lloyd jones
who actually came here last episode as
an x-wing pilot for doing the physical
embodiment of luke skywalker here
hamilton just did a great job capturing
mark hamill's posture from return of the
jedi on this he would speak in riddles
line notice his neck is sloped forward
like he definitely studied the tapes oh
that's crazy indoors yeah this episode
but it was written by john favreau and
apology together i think they might have
written words for luke with easier
consonant sounds to animate reliance
specifically on repetition like notice
in this clip have you heard anyone talk
like that back home do you remember back
home that k sound sits in the back of
the mouth uses less of the front part of
mouth than the lips and the teeth and
then the b and the m really just require
the lips to close so think about it back
home a lot easier to animate than a t
and an s which are more complex so
repeating the phrase back home back home
from our eyes it's much more lifelike i
really do think they were being
strategic about what words they try to
have this puppet pronounce
i love you eric i'd love you so much
we walked into this video i don't think
either one of us were expecting
such a detailed breakdown on a specific
choice of writing dialogue in order to
make
this deep fakey aging face replacement
crap work that much better that is a
really impressive analysis you put forth
you're keeping up with the corridor i
was about to say i thought i'd just
watch the corridor breakdown or a
behind-the-scenes featurette
it doesn't make me appreciate the
attention to detail they have to put
forth like okay so much actually went
wrong you can't just be the face we got
it so much work really sell this so we
gotta really make it convincing and we
show him speak it's gonna count luke
helps grogu remember the night of order
66 in the jedi temple on coruscant which
ahsoka teased for us last season on the
mandalorian someone took him from the
temple then his memory becomes
dark here we actually see it from
grogu's point of view all framed in the
cornea of an eye which initially
releases out from groku on the jungle
floor and then spreads outward to fill
the whole frame telling us that it is
really luke's eye peering into grogu's
memory as the memory begins listen
closely
yes first we hear the voices of jedi
children suggesting that grogu might
have initially been in the room or
around those young ladies that masta
anakin slaughtered or perhaps could have
been in a different padawan class
because we see these three jedi fighting
the 501st clone trooper battalion you
can tell it's them they get the same
blue plated armor these are the troopers
that anakin led into the temple the best
of the best which is bad news for the
jedi the two jedi on the outside are
robed but based on their hands they do
appear to be adults the one in the
middle is a man with long blonde hair
tied in a bun he does look a bit like
the jedi temple's battle master sin
dralig who at the time of order 66 was
teaching a class of padawans though it
is believed that innocent skywalker
killed him a security holocron showed
anakin slaying the students of the class
so i'm assuming this guy is probably
someone else we also don't know if these
jedi were aware grogu was behind them
because he does seem to be peering out
from some kind of concealed container i
still think there is some validity to a
theory that i think is crazy but i
really love that grogu could have been
hidden inside of the shell of r2d2
was present at the temple during the
massacre right after the massacre when
anakin brought him back to padme's flat
r2 had some pretty freaked out exchange
with threepio
and notice here that the trooper did not
say grab the kid he just pointed forward
and said go go go let's move i think
these strippers are really just moving
past something something like an
astrobec droid oblivious to what was
hidden inside
green and blue blades the blue blaster
bolts reflecting grosgu's eyes as he
reacts in terror and his eyes focus
specifically on that green lightsaber
hilts rolling toward him out of a dead
hand it's just also worth noting that
when rogue witnessed luke saving them
with his lightsaber that mandalore in
season 2 finale the color of the
security camera monitor was shaded in
monochrome rogue did not see that green
blade in action until luke came through
the doors and zipped up the blade back
in the hilt i'm wondering if grogu may
associate a green lightsaber blade with
that trauma from the night of order 66.
yoda saber might not be the cool toy
that grogu would be that eager to
revisit the pain of and as ahsoka said
grog's memory goes dark at this point he
now awakens from his memory in a totally
new location than where he was before
he's now at a riverbank meaning
revisiting that memory exhausted him
into a kind of coma for a period why
your ability to talk about such a
psychoanalysis traumatic event and then
just meanwhile
[Laughter]
yeah wow that's so heartbreaking i never
even considered all those possibilities
of what might have actually happened
with groku it is object identification
that activates his subconscious
traumatic like that's a triggering point
for him i'm not sure if it would be
because i mean if i look back on that
whole scene with luke and uh grogu and
mandalorian season two i mean he seemed
pretty like hopeful and optimistic yeah
he wasn't like hey yo get away i feel
like
[Music]
no
leave me you must
i feel like if it was that traumatic he
would have had a spasm or something when
luke showed up the first yeah he would
have been like sarah paulson in every
season of america
[Laughter]
i want to see some hysterical snot
acting from baby yoda mando meanwhile
wakes up to find ahsoka tano i'm an old
friend of the family yup me and luke's
war criminal dad used to be tight now
concept art in the credits suggested
that mando was actually gonna
instinctively fire at her but ahsoka
might have redirected that blast using
the force i guess like oh cool
blaster bolt ahsoka says there's nothing
now that will someday be a great school
groga will be its first student yes
confirming that the school that luke
later inducks his nephew into is
actually initially built to teach grogu
a student who i believe we will learn
will re-buff luke skywalker setting up
luke to not yet learn the error of the
jedi orthodoxy by the time ben defects
but at this point in history luke and
ahsoka are full of optimism there is no
place in the galaxy more safe than here
with luke
you sure about that
but one of the things that impresses
how much we should trust the jedi way at
this point in history i don't understand
why you're all right with skywalker's
decision to train the kid when you
wouldn't
because it was his choice i don't
control the wants of others yeah that
little sharp exhale from ahsoka reveals
the doubt of one teacher politely
disagreeing with the mentorship agreed
by another like she did not want to
train grogu because she sensed in that
kid the same fear of losing a loved one
that she saw in anakin but luke never
knew anakin is a man before darth vader
just a regretful withered old man under
the armor so luke believes he really can
be the guru that yoda and obi-wan were
to him i was gonna throw this out here
yeah you're right at the same time
though it's i think luke does know
anakin especially because like as you
see with this scene with groku he's able
to tap into his memories and his real
emotions so i feel like he's able in
return of the jedi tapping into the true
soul of anakin skywalker underneath the
dark side
so yeah just kind of throw that out
there i feel enlightened for just having
heard it yeah yeah
you want to say i get what you're saying
yeah how's that book coming along brian
mando and ahsoka debate over whether
groku should be called a foundling or
padawan but ahsoka offers to give grogu
the best guard chainmail on his behalf
so grogu won't be distracted by mando's
presence and i love this as mando takes
one last look at grogu sunlight shines
on his shoulder this is the same
sunlight we saw beaming down on goku
during their meditation through the
bamboo leaves a form of the force
surrounding and comforting them both and
now it gleams on the exact shoulder
where the mud horn sigil is on mando's
armor a sigil that mando chose as a
signet from the moment that grogu used
the force to save him the moment these
two were really fused together as amanda
starfighter departs groga reaches his
little hand as if trying to muster the
force to force pull his friend back to
him the manual crashes
he dies
don't try
do yes of course we call him yoda's
famous instruction why not
do
or do not
there is no try luke runs with grogo in
a backpack just like yoda rode his back
during the training on dagobah he does
the same kind of flips he did through
the swamp they climb up a bamboo stalk
and just sway with the breeze crouch the
entire hit twilight
crouching wide world exists in balance
feel the force all around you
[Music]
through the force you will find balance
as well and we hear the french horn of
john williams force theme first heard
when luke gazed out on the binary sunset
of tatooine and suspending them the
breeze like this is really just a
metaphor for how connecting with the
force is like floating amidst nature the
kind of approach luke takes with rey on
notch toe and between it all
balance luke has grogu balance on one
foot like the awkward handstands yoda
had him do and then later grogu watches
as luke's star wars kids with his
lightsaber and green blade reflecting in
his eyes again just like the sabers did
during order 66 so while he watches with
great interest i really do think he's
associating those two moments luke uses
one of those training remotes to test
grogu's reflexes like obi-wan used with
him on the falcon and a new hope groku
at first rolls it like a ball just like
how we turn that spherical knob on
mando's ship into a ball toy making it
feel especially cruel when this remote
zaps grogu when unlike luke he doesn't
have a lightsaber to deflect it i do
like how this training remote moves with
the same sudden stop-motioning shifts
that it did in 1977 grogu backflips away
from it eventually just straight up
destroying it and drowning it similar to
how grogu has quickly resorted to force
choking in the past getting a head start
i'm just doing the same thing to this
actor
shot's fired
now
is over 50 years old the same age anakin
skywalker would have been and if he had
many masters over the years as ahsoka
said roku's jedi training probably
exceeded luke's own ahsoka also says
sometimes the student guides the master
likely referring to her relationship
with master anakin whom she
personally went a lot throughout the
clone wars they go on to say sometimes i
wonder if his heart is in it
so much like your father
now i assume she's referring to
now that she sees a mentor doubting a
student just as anakin would do to her
doubt that she would later prove him
wrong on mando returns to tatooine and
joins boba fett fenix shannon black
santan the mods and the mayor's major
domo at this fun little moment ma'am
okays is on their payroll and has flown
off world which leads us to believe
the storm
is about to break
it was a scheduled vacation actually
and you'll notice as they strategize
boba's helmet sits on the throne just a
cool little way of signaling his
authority throughout all of this
yep especially over the plot it is kind
of sad what's happening with boba in the
optics of the public for the most part
yes i think if everyone had unanimously
liked the first four episodes it might
be a little bit different but yeah
people for the longest time like are we
going to get that boba movie oh we got a
mandalorian show is it about boba it's
all about bobo that's too bad oh bubba's
a mandalorian season two cool
all right it's a little bit different
than i imagined but still i'm on board
oh finally finally after years of
wanting it he's getting his own thing oh
wait a minute he's not really excited no
it's great that he's not in it but
it has been a very difficult journey for
old boba fett hasn't it i i wonder how
timora morrison feels yeah hey we liked
the first yeah two through four a lot
more than most people
we're the target audience because we're
enjoying kind of every part of it we see
the skull of the crate dragon that mando
and the tuscans and cop vance slayed now
strapped to the roof of a jawa sand
crawler that same great dragon's rib
cage now adorns the interior of the moss
pelgo saloon meaning they had to
disassemble and reassemble it piece by
piece to fit in through the door so i
love that they did this mando asked cobb
ban for some backup mos pelgo might be
good right now freetown
what
it's called freetown now we changed the
name
suits us better that weak wave
proprietor is once again played by w
earl brown who co-starred on hbo's dead
wood alongside timothy elephant the
breeze that was shot
on the vapor spire vein returns hitting
a wind chime signaling cobb to gaze out
on the horizon to see this slender
figure approaching this is just more
great western imagery to introduce this
newcomer teased by the title from the
desert comes a stranger sauntering into
view like david carradine this is cad
bane the duros bounty hunter from clone
wars and bad batch involved in a number
of plots like holding senators hostage
to free the annoyingly voiced zero to
hut
also helping sidious locate a bunch of
force-sensitive kids for a sith army
later on joining the separatists who had
tried to assassinate palpatine and then
a bad batch kidnapping omega also in an
unfinished clone wars episode it was
going to be revealed that the dent in
boba fett's helmet was caused by a duel
with cadbane i expect that to come up
next episode along with cadvayne's past
scuffle with fenix shand that we saw
last year on bad match he wears vam
braces on his wrists and he has these
breathing tubes that feed into his
cheeks this is not because he needs him
to breathe normally but to protect him
from getting force choked by a jedi and
i love how his skin is now a paler blue
and wrinkled compared to his animated
form it's a really cool way of showing
how time has dried out this bounty
hunter he says
[Music]
and all you've got to do is stay put and
let things play out silly and voice work
by corey burton who voiced him on the
animated series this guy's known for his
versatile voiceovers throughout the
disney parks in a number of right so
keeps his eyes hidden for most of the
exchange until i'm sorry i didn't catch
your name
reveal
i'd be careful where i was sticking my
nose if i were you
these eyes are so effectively alarming
to see in live action signaling the
steely clint eastwoodie anger that cobb
didn't already know who he was and he
drops a great line about his nose
despite cad not having a nose that jumpy
dip baby scott is played by jj dansha
who has actually been somewhere
morrison's stunt double in past episodes
in this tense standoff so well edited
the deputy fidgets and shifts his weight
around this is what causes cod to take
his eyes off cad for just a split second
as the drawing happens but since cad
never took his eyes off cobb he wins a
draw shooting cobb in the shoulder just
a flesh wound but he did see him in his
shooting arm a pretty serious injury the
deputy meanwhile he ain't got no respect
i love how afterward joe takes the
fastest glance of the deputy but still
runs over to the marshal
but it still reminded me of those nurses
going for mr burns instead of smithers
[Laughter]
yeah i mean i was so in the moment of
what happened and just knowing who cad
bait is but like at the moment like he
killed him
because even though you know you're
pointing out that because of the fact
oliphant darted his eyes and that's why
uh cad band was able to win that duel i
still think even if there was no darting
of eyes catbane would have would have
can't be gonna take on jedi
yeah yeah i think you would have been
able to take him down regardless of
whatever darting of eyes happened yeah i
mean he's yeah
cob vanth is pretty good but he's not
like this infamous like galaxy wide
bounty yeah
and i think with him even being more
saturated blue it might have detracted
from his eyes a little bit so i'm
wondering if with the color palette kind
of a grayer overtone with it it allows
his eyes to pop that much more and feel
more alien
like an alien threat like more like ufo
reminiscent in a way yeah it's like if
you make the blue more real than the
reveal of just how massive and menacing
the eyes are gets greater i think in the
process yeah two pikes bring a camp tono
into gossip whip sanctuary cantina where
the usual faces can be seen there's
rhodium there's an r3x dealer there's an
rsm never leaves your van there's a
snivian with beautiful hair maybe she's
born with this stevians are a throwback
to a snaggletooth action figure kenner
modeled on a background extra that you
can see in a cantina in a new hope but
this camptono goes boom a classic
gangland bombing like the al capone
bombing in the entire damn brother said
that
i actually read the opening crawl of the
first star wars film i love this notice
how one frame before that camtard i
didn't know that is about to say
something as if she realized the moment
before it was about to happen now the
band in the scene includes that bit
guitarist and that astromech drummer but
no max rebo
source because somehow he also survived
the explosion of jabba's got max has
broken in on it do not join his band a
little detail on the transition here the
flames transition right to luke's
finished school giving us just a few
frames showing that fire blazing up from
beneath the schools we're telling this
school's own future fiery end now inside
this temple our shelves contain a number
of artifacts which in the wide profile
shot may include a couple withered books
on that shelf perhaps these are the
sacred jedi texts that luke actually
spent this era of his life tracking down
luke unwraps mando's gift to grogu best
guard chainmail armor knee thrill
actually the framing from luke's
perspective already drapes it over
grogu's body fits like a glove but luke
gives him another option this
[Music]
is a lightsaber
[Music]
it belonged to my teacher master yoda
[Music]
and now
i'm offering it to you
john williams yoda theme returns here
and yes i love the return of yoda's
shorter lightsaber first scene an attack
of the clones falling from his hands
during his duel with sidious and revenge
of the sith it was revealed to be
destroyed in darth vader comics number
one however a later comic age of the
rebellion does hint that yoda might have
reassembled the saber when he was on
dagobah so he probably had it with him
on dig about when he died when luke was
there keeping it in that wooden box if
you think about it just like luke's
lightsaber was kept in a wooden box in
maz kanata's basement this being a
child's choice between two lives is
another parallel between these series
and lone wolf and cub when a child is
made to choose between the sword and a
toy the path of a warrior or the life of
a normal stupid kid
likely remains about the danger of green
lightsabers from his most traumatic
memory and the way he reached out for
mando i think it is likelier that he's
going to choose that bescar armor
especially when i think this series is
setting him up to wield the dark saber
anyway he is a being of both mandalorian
in jedi custody just as harvey's law was
thousand percent that's why poetry
arrives
very very maybe break the curse too
begins to open might be a small detail
but the episode's audio description
specifically call this out i think we
cut away right as grogu was about to
utter his first word what would that
word have been i wonder mando
or maybe just pukes up like 30 frogs
but hey if you live in the chicago area
you've got to come see new rock stars
live on february 11th 8pm talia hall
ticket link in the description we're
gonna be doing some wacky fun stuff that
we never do here on the channel please
come out to meet us you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
new rockstars and subscribe to rockstars
for more analysis of everything you'd
love thanks for watching bye bye
that was great that was very
enlightening 100 agree that's what we
were saying in our review of what's
gonna happen with grogu yep hundred
thousand percent
one that he'll get his own show
girl the book of grogu
yeah part way through shift focus and
just be about luke for like four
episodes called grover's halfway across
the galaxy
oh man all right guys well keep a
lookout for a reaction to the finale you
can subscribe click that bell
hit that like button more importantly
keep up to date with new rock stars the
whole team they're a hard working team
man it's more than just voss there's a
whole bunch of people there 45 people on
the videos hundreds hundreds hundreds of
factories this is a community yeah the
compound somewhere just cranking around
all right guys we'll catch you soon
[Music]